[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل الزوايا هو من
جميع الجوانبه
[تصفيق]
في كاس العالم راقصود سانجو يعزفون على
وتر الانتصار الارجنتين بطلا لكاس العالم
[تصفيق]
معي انتهاء كاس العالم العربيه 360 ترفضوا
لحظات لا تنسى وسبعه نجوم جذب الانظار
بشده الله
القوات الاوكرانيه وخنادق الجيش الاوكراني
القوات الروسيه تبعد في هذا الاتجاه حوالي
500 متر فقط من هذا المكان
صفر الى الخنادق العربيه على خط التماس في
جبهه بخموت الاوكرانيه
وفي القضايا السياسيه التي شغلت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعيه تتابعونا ايضا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في هذه المشاهد المباشره الارجنتين على
عرش كره القدم ميسي يجاور العظماء ويرفع
كاس العالم 2022 ويتحرروا من ضمن مارادونا
في كاس العالم للمره الثالثه في تاريخه
منتخب الارجنتين يحصد كاس العالم لتمثل
هذه المباراه صراعا بين جيلين الاول
لخواتيم مسيره ليونيل ميسي والثاني لبدايه
عهد سيطره كيليان مبابي
ركلات الترجيح بنتيجه 4 - 2 بعد ما تغلبت
على فرنسا
بثلاثه اهداف لكل فريق
كره القدم ويرفع كاس العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من الدوحه من فضل العربيه ليس
بازاري ومن باريس ايضا فادي الدهوك اهلا
بكما يعني ابدا معك ليث الارجنتين عاشت
الحلم وحققته
الصوره من عندك تتحدث انت توسط هؤلاء
المشجعين الفرحين بفوز الارجنتين وقائدها
ميسي خليهم يعني هم الذين يتحدثون لعمر
المكان ليس للنوم او للراحه بل الذهاب الى
وسط الدوحه لاقامه الاحتفالات مره اخرى
ميسي والمنتخب الارجنتيني هناك كثير من
اتى من السعوديه
فازت على الارجنتين وصحتها شوي واخذت كاس
العالم نعم نعم هناك شخص من السودان ممكن
تقول مبروك لحساب الارجنتيني بنيل هذه
البطوله مبروك لميسي بنيه لهذا البطوله
الغاليه ونذكر الشعب القطريه لحقاوه
الاستقبال والكرم ونشكر الحكومه على جمال
التنظيم روعه
صح نعم نعم انت من وين من السعوديه من
المدينه المنوره
يقول مبروك الاعظم لاعب في تاريخ كره
القدم ليونيل ميسي وشكرا قطر لهذا التنظيم
والصراحه الشعب الارجنتين يستحق هذه
الفرحه لانهم تعبهم بدايه البطوله واكثر
جمهور قطر جمهور الارجنتين يستحق هذا
الشيء والله راويه في هذا الشاب من تاج
باكستان ولكن لا يتكلم من العربيه
والانجليزي تحكي عربي انت ثانكيو ميسي
اه هذا بس جربت احكي معه بلغات مختلفه
ولكن صعب يعني ما عرفت اتواصل معه كان بده
يحكي كلمه وهاي الكلمه تنكس طيب ايش يعني
هنا الشباب مثل ما حكينا راويه سيدتجهون
يعني بدات تخف الحشود للتوجه الى وسط
الدوحه طبعا احنا بعد شوي بدنا ننتقل الى
هناك الطريق ما عاده هي 20 دقيقه ولكن مع
الازدحامات سوف تكون اكثر بقليل اتوقع
القادمه
همم يذهب همم لاعبوا المنتخب الارجنتيني
للاحتفال مع جماهيرهم هناك وايضا هناك همم
المزيد من الفعاليات فعاليات الالعاب
الناريه همم نكون بانتظار الصور الجميله
والفرحه معك ومع زملاءنا انتقل الى باريس
وفادي فادي يعني المنتخب الفرنسي قدم
مباراه رائعه ايضا يستحق الفوز اا مبابي
سجل ثلاثه اهداف الصوره من عندك همم يعني
هي يعني هي انجازات فرنسيه ولكن بغصه لم
تكتمل لحمل الكاس
نعم راويه الافراح عندي كما ترون شارع او
جده الشانزلي بدات تفرغ من المشجعين
الفرنسيين الذين كانوا هنا بالالاف
يتهيئون للاحتفال بفوز المنتخب الفرنسي
محاوله التحدث مع احدهم صيغتهم
لكن
سايفون 2018
الامطار تتهاطل بشكل كثيف الان واا تقريبا
معظم الجماهير عادت الى منازلها الشرطه
همم تؤمن عوده هؤلاء لمحطات المترو والى
المداخل التي كانت سدتها سابقا
لتامين الاحتفالات التي كان من المتوقع ان
تشد التدفق ل 10,000 ربما مئات الالاف من
الفرنسيين
فتحت من جديد
لا يوجد الا الشرطه
بداوا بفتح الطرقات المؤديه الى هنا هذه
سياره شرطه همم تتقدم وهم فتحوا بعض
المداخل الجانبيه لكن ما زالوا منتشرين
هنا تحسبا لحدوث اي مشكله حتى الان لا
يوجد شيء يذكر حصل لم الاحظ همم
عمليات تخريب او اي شيء همم او مراسلات او
مشكلات بينها المنتخبين وبالمناسبه قبل
خليل همم قبل همم المباشر كان هناك مشجعين
للمنتخب الارجنتيني وهدفه لميسي امام
الكاميرا ولم يحدث اي شيء على العكس تماما
الكل كان همم يتعامل مع الموضوع بروح
الرياضيه ويتقبل هذه الخساره المشجعين
الفرنسيين اكثر راويه شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
اخوك
من الدوحه
انتقل الى نايف الثقيل مراسل العربيه من
الدوحه نايف اين تتواجد ااا طبعا يعني
اجواء فرح الجماهير الارجنتينيه
فرحه بهذا الانتصار التاريخي اا بعد عام
1978و 1986 بقطر اليوم الارجنتين تحقق هذا
اللقب التاريخي انقل لنا الاجواء
[موسيقى]
واحتفالات تاريخيه ويعود الفضل الى ان
الملعب كان اكثر من ثلاث ارباع المدرجات
كان الجماهير ارجنتينيه لذلك تشاهدين صخر
بالجماهير الاكبر نحن الان نقف في احد
المناطق المسموحه لنا اعلام بمحاذاه
مساواه الجماهير وهي متجهه وتحتفل باتجاه
الموت هذه احد الفعاليات التي تقيمها لجنه
المنظمه همم للاحتفال في الفريق الفائز
والاحتفال في الفريق الفائز كما تشاهدين
المشاهد الان امامك
يعني هناك توافد اذا من كل
المناطق بالدوحه الى هذه النقطه للاحتفال
بفوز المنتخب الارجنتيني نشاهد اصلا مرور
المشجعين الى اين يتجهون نايف
طبعا ما زالت الجماهير الارجنتينيه تحتفل
داخل الملعب حتى الان في الساحات الداخليه
الملعب ولكن بسبب ضعف الاتصالات وعدم ان
كان البث من هذه من هذه تلك المنطقه
انتقلنا الى هناك تشاهدين الان
اعذرني على المقاطعه ان ننتقل الى ليث انت
تتواجد همم الدوحه ايضا ولكن اين تحديدا
انقل لنا الصوره
نحن ناس معاك
المكان تم اخلاؤه بالكامل بانتظار المنتخب
الارجنتيني الذي سيقوم الذي سيصير من
منطقه الملعب في عمق الصوره الى هذه
المنطقه وهم طبعا يحملون كاس العالم برفقه
ميسي طبعا وانخل وغيرها من اللاعبين كما
تشاهدين القوات الامنيه تحرس المكان لا
يوجد الكثير من الماره بل بالاحرى لا يوجد
مره نحن دخلنا قبل تقرير لهذه المنطقه
ونشاهد القوات الامريكيه قوات الشرطه
القطريه وهي تاتي الى هذه الجهه متجهه الى
الى منطقه الابراج لحراسه المنطقه حتى يتم
اخلاءها بالكامل بالكامل الجميع على روبه
الاستعداد نشاهد الشرطه جميعهم يلتفتون
الى الجمهور يتاكدون ان جميع من يقف هنا
لا يت- لا يتجاوز هذا الحد وهمم طبعا
بانتظار المنتخب الارجنتين الذي فاز بكاس
العالم هذا العام نحن سنكون معكم اكيد
مباشره من هنا
وانهيا بانتظار وصول هذا المنتخب الفائز
بكاس العالم في مونديال قطر هذا العام
الفريق الارجنتيني وهو يستعرض الكاس
ويشارك جمهوره هذه الفرحه شكرا جزيلا لك
ابقى معي
نذهب الى بيونس
ولينارصد هذه الفرحه والجماهير
الارجنتينيه
بالالاف والملايين ربما همم بهذه الصور
المباشره من هناك يعني المنتخب الارجنتيني
همم فاز ب همم صعوبه ولكنه قدم
مباراه تاريخيه وكبيره
والان الظاهره الجديده ميسي يرفع كاس
العالم بعد ان كان الظاهره الاولى
مارادونا وحققه اللقى في مونديال المكسيك
نشاهد عشاق الكره كره القدم عشاق
الارجنتين وميسي فرحونا بهذا الانتصار
التاريخي
هو يوم الارجنتين
التي احرزت اللقب للمره الثالثه في
تاريخها بعد عامين 78 و 86 لليان يعني
دعينا نتشارك هذه الفرحه مع الارجنتينيين
في فينوس ايرس الذين يحتفلون
لا شك انه الكثير من المحطات المميزه همم
والكبرى حصلت في هذا المونديال مونديال
قطر الذي اقيم لاول مره في دوله عربيه
واصلا شاهدنا ليونيل ميسي وهي وهو يلبس
البسط الخليجي اثناء التشويش ما اكثر ما
لافتك في هذا الموضوع
كانت بطوله من ناحيه المباريات والنتائج
والمفاجاه او من ناحيه همم
المنتخبات ولكن مالفات اللي هو بالبدايه
يعني الكثير من المحطات همم جماهير الان
جماهير الارجنتين التي نراها هنا كانت
جماهير الارجنتين وصلت منذ بدايات البطوله
يعني استاجرت شارع بالدوحه وبدات تعيش فيه
وكانه بايته يعني بيت شارع تاكل به وتنام
يعني دائما هي الجماهير الارجنتيني نحن
اتعرفنا عليها نحن يعني بالبرازيل كانت
جماهير الارجنتين تذهب الى كوبا كابانا
بسياراتها تناوب بسياره لا 30 يوما حتى
تشاهد
الكاس العالم يعني هذه معروفه جماهير
الارجنتينيه بجنون بالمجال وبتشجيعه
لمنتخبنا المحطات همم طبعا يعني بهذه
البطوله بهذه البطوله بالتحديد همم
المنتخبات العربيه قدمت لنا همم اداء يعني
نفخر به وخاصه المنتخب المغربي همم بدايه
من المنتخب السعودي المنتخب السعودي فاز
على الارجنتين التي هي تتواجد الان بطله
المنتخب السعودي كان اكبر مفاج او اول
مفاجاه بهذه البطوله همم المنتخب التونسي
فاز على منتخب فرنسا الذي وصل الى الادوار
الدوري النهائي طبعا ياتي من يقول انه كان
يلعب احتياط ولكن فزع على منتخب فرنسا ال-
همم خروج البرازيل طبعا وهي كانت اكثر
المرشحين لهذه لهذا اللقب همم بالنهايه
بنهايه ما حطات وابرز محطه بالنسبه لنا
نحن وهي منتخب المغرب يعني المنتخب
المغربي وصل الى نصف نهائي يعني نحن ما
كنا نحلم انه نفكر بان ممكن اي منتخب عربي
او افريقي يصل الى هذه الى هذا الدور يعني
الجماهير المغربيه ايضا كهذه جماهير
الارجنتين اظهرت لنا انه هي همم تدعم
منتخبه هي تحب كره القدم عاشقه لكره القدم
عاشقه لمباريات كاس العالم همم ذهبت وراء
فقط
عندما يكون منتخب يعني انا الرجاء
المنتخب المغربي همم سيكون لهم بعد هذه
البطوله بالفعل همم مستقبل مختلف تماما
دخلوا به موته
يوما الاسعار اللاعبين سترتفع الطلبات
عليهم سيرتفع الرجراجي قال قبل بدايه
البطوله قبل اول فوز فاز به قال انه نحن
انا اريد ان اثبت انه لماذا لا يتهافت على
مدربين عرب اي من اي منتخب اوروبا او اي
فريق اوروبي او اجنبي بينما نحن نتهافت
عليهم يعني وبالفعل هو اثبت انه مدرب همم
يعني من الممكن ان يكون مطلوبا بعد هذه
يمكن ابرز المحطات وحتى يعني اللاعبون همم
المنتخب الياباني مثلا كان بارزا من
المنتخب الياباني بهذه البطوله انه افادنا
على المانيا فزع على اسبانيا كان يخرج
المنتخب الياباني بعد الفوز حتى من غرفه
تبديل الملابس كما دخلها همم نظيفه مرتبه
حتى انه ينظف كانه تنظف في المدرجات يعني
اكثر من اكثر من همم جمهور يعني كان يقلد
همم مثل اعطوا درسا
للجماهير بضروره تنظيف اي مكان يكون فيه
ليليان ابقى معي سنذهب الى نايف الثقيل
نايف همم نحن نشاهد فرحه الجماهير
الارجنتينيه وايضا توافد الناس اا
للاحتفال بفعاليات في مناطق عده بالدوحه
بفوز الارجنتين للمره الثالثه في تاريخها
همم ما الذي يعني انت كمراسل خلال تخطيطك
لهذه البطوله ما الذي
لفتتك ابرز اللحظات التي غطيتها
بالتاكيد ابوسلاح اللحظات الاحداث الدراما
التكيه التي حصلت اثناء المباراه يعني كنا
فيها في الخارج في فتره تسجيل الهدفين بعض
الجبهه وقليل من الجماهير الارجنتينيه
ضمنت اللقب وخرجت مبكرا حتى لا تدخل في
هذه الزحمه التي تشاهدينها الان ولكن
تفاجات بالتعادل المفاجئ وامتداد المباراه
الى شواط الاضافيه ادعوني اصف لك المشهد
الان العناصر الامن البطوله تسعه جاهدا
الى همم سرعه تسيير الاسود الى محطه
المترو هي محطه الوحيده اللي نقل الجماهير
حتى لا يكون هناك ازدحام في الخلف هناك
منطقه قدام الشال وايضا الملعب هذه
المنطقه لا تتسع نهائيا للاعداد الكبيره
همم موجوده الان هناك همم 88,000 مشجع
داخل الملعب وايضا نفس عددهم في المنطقه
الخارجيه لم يتمكنوا من الدخول لذلك تسعى
الان القوات الامنيه الى ابعادها هؤلاء
الجماهير
وتوزيعهم الى مناطق مت جديده في الدوحه
لاستكمال الاحتفالات نعلم ان هناك ست
مناطق في الدوحه مخصصه للاحتفالات
الجماهير
سيتم همم تسهيل مغادتهم
نحن معك
حاله تصف لك عشق الجماهير
الارجنتينيه وكيف تتنقل كما ذكرت ليليان
قبل قليل تتنقل خلف منتخب
الارجنتينيه تردد همم سوف تشاهدون ميسي
وسيجلب لنا الكاس حتى اليوم قبل بدايه
المباراه استمروا بترديد هذه العبارات
وايضا داخل المدرجات وبالاخير تحقق ما
كانوا يقولونه وحق وجلب لهم ميسي الكاس
سعاده لا توصف من الجمل نعم نعم
الاعلام
مبروك الفوز الله يبارك فيك الله يبارك
فيك تعبنا تعبنا الصراحه انت من وين من
الامارات
والله المباراه اعصاب بصراحه
اكيد اكيد
كاس العالم
بسالك سؤال لما حط يده على كاس العالم
وكبر كاس العالم وايش كان شعور والله احلى
شعور احلى شعور تريناها من سنين الحمد لله
تعال تعال
ههه مبروك مبروك
يا اخي ميسي الحمد لله لك الحمد الحمد
يوسف 2014
ابقى معي نايف سنذهب الى ليث بزاري
الموكب ربما اصبح قريبا الموكب الذي يقل
المنتخب الارجنتيني مع الكاس تفاصيل معك
يا ليل
حتى هذه اللحظه نشاهد قوات الشرطه التي
تتجول في المنطقه وتتاكد من الحراسه سنكون
راويه بشكل حصري هنا على درب الروسيل لرصد
موكب المنتخب الارجنتيني بقياده ميسي طبعا
سوف يمر من هنا من هذا البوليفارد او هذه
الجاده متجهه الى الابراج في الجهه الاخرى
لي جمهور المشجعون هنا على جانبي الطريق
وبكثره ليس فقط ارجنتينيون بل مشجعين
شاهدت برازيليين شاهدت مليارتدي العالم
السعودي شاهدت من يرتدي اعلام دول العربيه
الجميع بانتظار هذا الموكب على احر من جبل
هنا الجميع
المنتخب الارجنتيني الذي رابح الكاس هذا
العام ليكون هنا في هذه المنطقه وسوف نكون
معكم اكيد مباشره
بانه اليوم هذه الاحتفالات تتزامن مع
احتفالات دوله قطر
يوم الوطني الذي يصادف اليوم الثامن عشر
من ديسمبر واصلا كان في هنالك احتفالات
اذهب اليك ليليان همم هل كان واضحا منذ
البدايه ان المنتخب الارجنتيني هو الذي
سيحقق هذه النتيجه هذا الفوز التاريخي هلا
بالنسبه لالك اكيد اكثر واضح ولا لالي
الجميع
بالفعل عندما بدات الارجنتين بهذه البطوله
وخسرت اول مباراه لها امام السعوديه كنا
توقعنا انه ستخرج يعني اذا لم تخرج من دور
المجموعات ستخرج من دور همم
السته عشر لان لا احد يعني لم يتوقع ان
تصل الى هنا الان مشجعين المنتخب
الارجنتيني هو مشجعين مشجعوه ميسي طبعا
كانوا يتوقعون طبعا انه لهم امل دائما انه
بهذه ولكن دائما المفاجاه هي ما كانت همم
عنوان هذه البطوله بكل دور من مشوار يعني
همم ان يغادر كل ما نغادر المنتخبات التي
غادرت وهي دائما ما يدخل كل منتخب به اي
بطوله باي مباراه دائما المشجعون كانوا
يخافون من اخر لحظات المباراه دائما يعني
دائما هكذا بالبرازيل مثلا عندما خرجت
البرازيل باخر لحظه من الشوط الاضافي
الثاني عدله واخدونا الى ركلات الترجيح
وتتاهل ونحن وخرجنا يعني
الارجنتين ابدا همم هي من المرشحين طبعا
ولكن لا احد كان ابدا همم متاكد انه اي
منتخب من الممكن ان يصل الى المباراه
النهائيه نعم شكرا جزيلا لك ليليان تنوري
يعني ونحن مشاهد هذه الصور المباشره هذه
النوافذ فعليا من يونس ايرس همم ايضا من
دار له سيل حيث الجميع ينتظر مرور المنتخب
الارجنتيني حاملا كاس هذه البطوله شكرا
جزيلا لك ليليان
اعود اليك نايف ااا يعني نشاهد هذه
الجماهير التي تهدف باسم
ميسي
الصوره من عندك الاجواء الفرحه
كل اللغات يا راويه بكل الاجناس يحتفون
ميسي ميسي ميسي ميسي ميسي
[تصفيق]
جلب السعاده للجميع هنا انا ساحاول التقط
بعض اللقطات
ثانكيو شكرا كيف شايف الفوز لا لا ممتاز
تمام
الجول الثالث مصيبه هذا
الحمد لله
الحمد لله الحمد لله الله يسعدك
فرنسيه حزينه
جدا
راويه ادعي لي يا اخي اللقاء
قلبي بالحرب
الفراسه ما فازت الخزينه
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
الارجنتين السعودي فقط
ههه
فرنسيه
معاويه طبعا يقول انه همم لوما ذهبت
لفرنسا سافرح تذهب للارجنتين وهذا ينقل لك
صوت التعاطف الكبير نعم اجواء الاحتفالات
مستمره سنعود اليك دعنا الان نذهب الى هذا
الفاصل لن نتابع بعده هذه التغطيه شكرا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم من جديد من الانتصارات المفاجئه
الى الدموع والاهداف الرائعه
كاس العالم قطر 2022 بعد اربعه اسابيع من
التباري والتنافس بين المنتخبات العالميه
دوله مشاهدينا نعود معكم الى ابرز اللحظات
التي ميزت هذا المونديال كاس العالم 2022
والتي ستبقى عالقه في ذاكرتي جميع محبي
كره القدم
البدايه من المغرب ستبقى دوره هذه السنه
مثل ما ذكرنا مرتبطه بانجاز المنتخب
المغربي بعد ان اصبح اسود الاطلس اول فريق
افريقي وعربيه يصلوا الى المربع الذهبي
للبطوله بعد مسار الاستثنائيا اثار اعجاب
متتبعين الكره وفاز المغرب باول المباراه
له في المونديال منذ عام
19980 والثاني على الاطلاق بتامين فوز
مثير اثنين صفر على بلجيكا قبل ان يتجاوز
كندا ثم يقصي اسبانيا والبرتغال من دوري
الثمن والربع
وفي اكثر النتائج غير المتوقعه شهد
مونديال قطر فوزا تاريخيا للمنتخب السعودي
على نظيره الارجنتيني المتوجي بالمونديال
مرتين والذي حل بالمركز الثاني او اللي
فاز هذا منذ قليل بقياده الاسطوره ليونيل
ميسي توقع الكثير ان تكتسح الارجنتين
السعوديه غير ان لاعبي المدرب ارفي رونار
حققوا المفاجاه الكبرى وانتصروا في
مباراتهم الاولى
فيفا
وفي نتيجه اخرى غير متوقعه تعرضت المانيا
بطله العالم 2014 لهزيمه مفاجاه امام
اليابان في المباراه الافتتاحيه للفريقين
قبل ان تتعادل مع اسبانيا وتفوز على
كوستاريكا بصعوبه ولم يساعد الفوز الاخير
رفاقه على تجاوز دور المجموعات لتكون هذه
المره الاولى 80 عاما التي يفشل فيها
المنتخب الالماني في التقدم الى مراحل
خروج المغلوب من البطوله وقال هذا بعد
الخروج من دوري المجموعات ان يحصل الامر
بهذه الطريقه يبدو وكانه في المرعب
دخلت ستيفاني برابير التاريخ في هذه
البطوله ايضا كاول امراه تحكم او تحكم في
مباراه في كاس العالم للرجال وجنبا الى
جنب مع مساعدتيها نويزا بعد من البرازيل
وكريم دياز من المكسيك شكلت الفرنسيه جزءا
من ثلاثي تحكيم نساء بالكامل لاداره
مباراه كوستاريكا ضد المانيا في مباراتهما
الاخيره بالمجموعه الخامسه ياتي ظهور
فريبارا الاول في كاس العالم بعد ان اصبحت
في عام 2019 اول حكم تتولى مسؤوليه اداره
مباراه في دوري الدرجه الاولى الفرنسيه
واول من اداره مباراه في دوري ابطال
اوروبا والى الاسطوره الارجنتينيه
حتى قبل المباراه كتب البالغ من العمر 35
عاما التاريخ في هذه البطوله حيث سجل في
المباراه رقم 1,000 في مسيرته وساهم في
جميع المباريات التي فاز فيها منتخب بلادي
في هذا المونديال الذي اعلن قبل ايام ان
كاس العالم 2022 سيكون اخر ظهور دولي له
ومن الاسطوره الارجنتينيه الى الاسطوره
البرتغاليه كريستيانو رونالدو من المحتمل
ان تكون هذه اخر كاس عالم يشارك فيها
كريستيانو رونالدو وبدلا من النهايه
المجيده التي كان يتمناها غادر المهاجم
البالغ من العمر 37 عاما المونديال باكيا
بعد ان هزم فريقه او هزم على يد المغرب في
ربع النهائي والشهداء رونالدو غير قادر
على اخفائي مشاعره وهو يغادر الملعب في
السادس ثم ماما الى غرفه تبديل ملابس
المنتخب البرتغالي بعد ان توالت خيبات
الامل التي عاشها في مونديال قطر حيث لم
يدخل رسميا في مبارتين متتاليهتين مفاجاه
اخرى غير متوقع
هذا الكاس كاس العالم 2022 حيث جاء راقص
سامبا الى مونديال قطر باعتبارهما
المرشحين الاوفر حظا لخطف الكاس الذهبيه
غير ان الفريق
ظهر في جل المباريات باداء متوسط لم
يؤهلهم لتجاوز دور الربع ضد المنتخب
الكرواتي ولم يقدم المنتخب البرازيلي في
المونديال اداء يشفع له بالتتويج بالكاس
باستثناء امطار شباك كوريا الجنوبيه
بالاهداف ورقصات الاحتفال طبعا هذه
الرقصات المجنونه التي ستظل عالقه في
اذهان محبين نجوم السامبا رغم ان مذيع
القطر لن يكون ذكرى جيده بالنسبه للبرازيل
[موسيقى]
ادانت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه الهجوم على
قوات الامن العراقيه بشمال البلاد الذي
ادى الى مقتل عدد من افراد الشرطه بينهم
ضابط واكدت الخارجيه في بيان نقلته وكاله
الانباء السعوديه على رفض المملكه التام
لكل اشكال العنف والاعمال الارهابيه وجددت
الخارجيه السعوديه دعم السعوديه لكل
الجهود الرميه الى القضاء على الارهاب
والتطرف بجميع اشكاله وصوره وتشفيه في
منابع تمويلح
[موسيقى]
كشفت مجله البريطانيه الكبيره
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين امريكا سنجر اكد
امكانيه وقف الحرب في اوكرانيا من خلال
الدبلوماسيه محذرا من ابعاد روسيا عن
ممارسه السياسه الاستراتيجيه وان الرغبه
في تفكيك موسكو قد تطلق العنان لفوضا
نوويه عامه
روسيا مرتب ضد اوكرانيا تطالب اطراف دوليه
بوقف الحرب عبر تسويه دبلوماسيه شامله
احد كبار الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين اشار
وحسب مجله البريطانيه الى ضروره وقف
المواجهات والحد من نشوب حرب عالميه
الوقت يقترب للبناء على التغييرات
الاستراتيجيه التي تحققت ودمجها في هيكل
جديد لتحقيق السلام من خلال المفاوضات
كيسنجر كان اعلن عن اقتراحات ومسارات لم
تؤيدها اوكرانيا ودول غربيه
محذرا من ان الرغبه في تفكيك روسيا قد
تطلق العنان لفوضى نوويه عامه مشددا على
عدم ابعاد روسيا عن ممارسه السياسه
الاستراتيجيه لان الامر يمكن ان يحول
اراضيها التي تضم 11 منطقه زمنيه الى فراغ
متنازع عليه ومخاطر حقيقيه بسبب وجود الاف
الاسلحه النوويه باعتبارها واحده من اكبر
قوتين نوويتين في العالم
وبالتزامن قدم كيسنجر مقترحات لحلول ممكنه
ربما تساهم في وقف الحرب وجدتها كيف غير
مناسبه وقف النار وانسحاب اسيا الى الخطوط
الاماميه ما قبل الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير بقاء ملف شبه جزيره القرم محل
مفاوضات اجراء استفتاء تحت اشراف دولي
للبث في امر الاراضي التي ضمتها روسيا في
في المقابل قال خبراء عسكريون وامنون ان
وقف حرب اوكرانيا يصطدم بعراقيل ابرزها
تجديد الاوكرانيين على خروج روسيا من
اراضيها كما دخلتها اول مره انسحاب الجنود
الروسي من اقليم دومباز ومناطق اخرى تمثل
5 مساحه اوكرانيا
فيما تعتبر موسكو انها حققت اهداف عمليتها
الخاصه بضم اقليم دومباس الى الاتحاد
الروسي وسط تسريبات عن امكانيه تخلي روسيا
عن مناطق مثل خرسون وزابولوجيا كما فعلت
بسحب جنودها من خارجيف
هو حسب تقارير امنيه فان روسيا تواصل
توسيع نفوذها من شبه جزيره القرم الى
ضواحي روستو جنوبا فيما تحسن اوكرانيا
ترسانتها العسكريه باسلحه اوروبيه
وامريكيه لاخراج القوات الروسيه من
اراضيها جاسم محسن العربيه
وانضم الينا من واشنطن فيليب كراوليا
المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
اهلا بك معنا ليلى سيد فيليب يعني
ماديلالات كلام
بدنا امامه اختراق للاطراف المتصارعه
بجدار هذه الازمه وبالتالي يمكن الذهاب
الى حوار جلوس على طاوله الحوار وانهاء
هذه الحرب بسلام
بالنسبه للمخاطر التي
تنطوي عليها استمراريه الحرب لفتره اطول
واحتماليات التصعيد وهو محيق في انه في
مرحله
لابد من حل عبر تفاوي هذا الصراع
وببساطه فهناك
اليوم الامور
الظروف اول محاوله توصل الى الظروف التي
تدفع طرفين للخوض في مفاوضات
ويبدو انه من الصعب جدا ان نتخيل اننا قد
نقترب الى حل
تتابعونا بعد الفاصل
يلحق بمدينه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ابهرت مقاطع مصوره عبر
الجو حشم الدمار الذي لحق بمدينه
ظهرت اغلبوا مبانيها مدمره بينما تشتعل
الحرائق كما نرى بهذه الصوره
الكاميرا العربيه دخلت الى خطوط المواجهه
في جبهه بخموت وواكبه المعارك من خنادق
الجيش الاوكراني مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
عدلنا التقيب التاليه
لكن الوضع يختلف كليا هذه المره ويمكنك ان
تسمع القصف الذي يعلو صوته كل ما اقتربت
من مناطق القتال قصف بجميع انواع الاسلحه
المتوفره للطرفين اما الدخول فقد كان صعبا
نسبه لعوره الطرق وسوء الاحوال الجويه
هذه الجبهه صعبه جدا هنا يجري قتال شرس
العدو يهاجم بشكل مستمر ونحن نعمل على
ايقافه ما كان عليهم ان يبداوا هذه الحرب
عندها لم نقل نفقد الارواح ولكن بالعوده
الى سؤالك هناك قتله والاعداد تتفاوت من
منطقه الى اخرى لكني لا استطيع ان اخبرك
باعداد القتلى بخصوص السلاح نحتاج الى
مزيد من الاسلحه ونتمنى ان تكون متطوره
وبشكل عام نحن في اهبه الاستعداد ونضرب
جنودنا على مستوى عالي حتى لا نسمح للعدو
باحت اراضينا هذه تغطيه حصريه لقناتي
العربيه هو الحدث من خنادق الجيش
الاوكراني المطله مباشره على منطقه تواجد
القوات الروسيه هذه تسمى الجبهه صفر
ادخل بسرعه الى هذا المكان ستكون امنا
العدو على خط التماس وانت هنا ستكون في
امان في الداخل وتحتميه من قصر المدفعيه
والرصاص العربيه والحدث حصريا في خنادق
الجيش الاوكراني في مواقع الجيش الاوكراني
في جبهه الاخوه الجبهه الاعنف والاشرف
تشاهدون اطلاق النار بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه لا يتوقف هذه
الجبهه هي الاكثر اشتعالا في الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني يمكنك سماع ايضا اطلاق
النار من جهه القوات الروسيه وكما تشاهدون
الجيش الاوكراني ايضا يقوم بالرد على
اطلاق النار من الجهاز الاخرى نحن الان
نشاهد بث مباشر عن طريق الكاميرا التي تم
وضعها هنا في هذه المنطقه طبعا هذه
المنطقه التمركز القوات الاوكرانيه وخنادق
الجيش الاوكراني القوات الروسيه تبعد في
هذا الاتجاه حوالي 500 متر فقط من هذا
المكان الذي نحن فيه عن طريق هذه الكاميرا
عن طريق البث المباشر الان يستطيع الجنود
هنا ان يراقبوا تحركات القوات الروسيه
الان نحن نشاهد بث مباشر لمواقع تمركز
الجيش الروسي في هذا الاتجاه حوالي 500
متر وابعد نقطه قد تكون حوالي 800 متر من
هذا اتجاه 12 تصدقات شاشتمبواني في
الفيديو
من داخل الخندق حركه القوات الروسيه من
خلف التل ومناطق تمركز الاليات والمعدات
الروسيه نحن نرى الان المنطقه التي
يتمركزون فيها اذا راعينا حركتهم في هذا
الاتجاه فهذه علامه هجوم نحونا هذا هو
الخندق الاخير في مناطق تمركز القوات
الاوكرانيه في جبهه باخوت في اتجاه هور
لافقه القوات الروسيه تبعد من هنا حوالي
500 متر فقط تتحركوا جبهه القتال في جبهه
باخوت وهي جبهه عريضه في هذا الاتجاه او
ذاك حسب قدره اي من القوتين الروسيه
والاكرانيه على اجبار الاخرى على
الانسحابي او التخلي عن موقعها هذه القناه
التي نحن فيها الان وهي مناطق تمركز الجيش
الاخراني عن ساعتها وقامت بحفرها وكانت
تتمركز فيها القوات الروسيه الى القوات
الاوكرانيه في عمليه هجوم مضاد استطاعت ان
تسيطر عليها لتصبح مواقع اوكرانيه لقناه
العربيه والحدث الذي فعادل من ضاق
الجيش الاوكراني
صوره اليوم والاربع سنوات القادمه لرفع
النجم الارجنتينيه ليونيل ميسي كاس العالم
2022 بقطر مرتديا العباءه الخليجيه ومحققا
النجمه الثالثه للمنتخب الارجنتيني
ذهبت هذه الساعه الاخباريه ننتقل الى
الزميل عازل عيدان واخبار الساعه تفضل
شكرا
العديد من الارقام القياسيه في هذا
المونديال سنتعرف عليها ايضا وبالاضافه
الى الملف الاخراني